[Music]  sorry I said it's the best thing  you know what you love you sure  [Music]  the hell are you  [Applause]  I'm a fan of yours the CEO will beat up  two prostitutes but then got acquitted  in court yesterday let me down I'm  transferring 20% of your cash for these  two girls I'm coming down to security  the rest I'm transferring to your wife  [Music]  account number  don't one man what take your child and  leave he won't hurt you again mr. Chan  has been called your company for years  isn't this his wife rich we try to  contact your wife again or if anything  unexpected should happen to her this  video will be sent to  [Music]  are you not this with selecting the  right or wrong  the girl who hurts men who hurt Mary  I could never figure it out  why did you have everyone  but me  the contact I'm here  why is it this but why is it spiders  tomb get stuck in the wrong webs  you  you